cardi b is getting real about motherhood
and explaining why she refuses to hire a
nanny like having a baby that like the
whole world wants to see and watch and
know
you just have to be very
overly protective the rapper covers
vogue singapore and inside the mag cardi
shares she originally thought she'd hire
help to travel with her while she works
quote everybody was so nervous for my
career and future but i kept telling
them it's easy trust me i'm going to
hire a nanny and she's going to travel
up and down with me it's not even going
to be a hassle but plans changed when
her daughter culture was born when the
baby got here i couldn't even think
about getting a nanny cardi's reason she
says she was afraid of anybody being
around her little girl besides her
family what does it mean to be a mother
it means everything it's it's like a
feeling that it's indescribable
it's like
like
love joy it's a switch and now cardi is
a mom of two she and her hubby offset
welcomed their son wave last september
and like any mama bear she wants to
raise her kiddos to be the best version
of themselves cardi says of culture i
want her to do amazing things when she
grows up i want her to be smarter than
me just be the better version of me i
just want to show people how beautiful
and how
precious she is she's so precious
seriously but despite her offset's
massive success she's determined to keep
them grounded oh yes honey the grammy
winner tells the mag they need to know
to never feel comfortable don't ever
feel like i'm going to get it because
i'm cardi and offset's kid they are
never going to know what struggle feels
like so they might not have that hunger
i had to leave the streets
cardi explains even though her kids are
well off she wants them to know that
when you work for things it's more
respected adding quote especially when
people see that you bust your ass for it
i feel like people have thrown so many
things so many different crazy obstacles
but when it comes to spoiling their kids
that's another story
what is that
it's a ticket a ticket is a million
girls
50 say 50.
you see that right earlier this week
offset gifted culture 50 000 in cash for
her fourth birthday oh snapping snap
snap that wasn't all the little one was
also treated to a trip to candytopia
girl ready to get active
good job kk
and the marshmallow pig
[Music]
[Applause]
you